bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you welcome back
to another episode of the Dean show
we're here every week same time same
Channel and if you don't catch us on the
TV all of our shows are at the th e Dean
show de and show com all of our guests
they have their own section and you can
go there view some of their shows learn
about this wonderful way of life we also
have the blog section there that you can
get a lot of our podcasts download an
mp3 format and share it put it on CD
share it with the world don't forget
about the dvds for dial volume 2 is out
now today we're going to be discussing
having a topic having some fun and being
serious at the same time and we're going
to let everyone get involved dunya dunya
I'm going to see where do we fit in this
we know that many of the distractions
that are distracting us have to revolve
around things in this dunya the man
chasing the woman the woman chasing the
man outside of marriage the people who
rather go to the night clothes rather
than the mustard the people that are
letting all the material things and
goods interfere with their obedience to
the one who created them dunya dunya so
now we're going to bring out our brother
and your brother came out to help us
with this topic and see where you fit in
and when you hear this you can also come
out and say the words dunya dunya and
then we have to ask ourselves are we
wanting to make the change so we can all
benefit from this program and the
non-muslims get to learn some new words
what are we saying when we say dunya
dunya and then if you see a Muslim who's
doing some of these things that we're
going to point out you can go to them
and say dunya dunya this is what we're
going to be discussing when we come back
here on the Dean show you don't want to
go nowhere
Allah there's only one word my man is
his messenger Allah not you like in the
love
o Allah there's only one where Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
salamo alaikum how are you doing how is
everything under family children
everything's all good in the hood under
percent huh all right you're not in the
hood you hear the Dean show absolutely
hamdullah all praises to the credit of
heavens and earth that he's United us
and we're here and you have your own
section on the Dean show calm that
people can read about you and watch some
of the previous shows that we've done
we're going to get straight to it I'm
going to before we start the topic
because I'm going to read out some
things okay and we're going to see if
this is dunya dunya or it's something
else and we'll discuss it but I want you
to just introduce this what is this word
what do we mean dunya but by dunya we
mean this worldly life and we're
specifically referring to you know being
attached to materialism being attached
to this you know things of this world
too much whether it's love of money or
its cars or its homes but any basically
we're frankly things where it may have
something to do with your your desires
and things that you crave your lust and
love of materialism love of money what
have you all those but it's important to
clarify that in in Islam it's not that
you're supposed to basically be a hermit
or just live in a cave somewhere and
totally shun the dunya one of the best
examples is the process headlam he gives
us how we should be on this earth like a
traveler so this is not the final
destination we're passing through this
earth and we focus on the final
destination so basically the best
analogy to that and basically possum
said be like a traveler who sits under a
tree he rests under a tree a little bit
and then he moves on he doesn't the tree
is not a major part of this journey now
he just rested under it for a little and
I said it's gone he's focusing on the
final destination same thing suppose
you're driving your car across the
country from New York all the way to
California
so you're going through the Midwest and
you see this huge sale on furniture
chairs and sofas and desks and shelves
all kinds of things for like you know a
dollar each dollar fifty brand new you
know if you drive by a place that has
you know leather sofas that would
normally cost you fifteen hundred
dollars for a dollar fifty cents what
are you going to do if you're a traveler
can you buy it can you buy the sofas and
all that put on top of your car no
because your focus is your final
destination I'm only passing through
this area so when you pass through and
your journeying through you only take
what you need for the journey so if I'm
going to go from point A to point B I
take what I need for the journey I get
enough gas for the journey I get enough
clothes and enough food for that journey
if I see tons and tons of electronics
and things that are free or almost free
I don't have time for them because I
need only what I need for the journey so
the advice then was for the Muslims to
take from this dunya what they need to
make it through the journey not to amass
you know tons and tons of mansions and
hundreds and hundreds of cars and and
try to amass millions and millions of
dollars because you don't need that for
the journey just take what you need with
you so that's the whole point it's the
discourages from being totally into the
dunya but at the same time it's not
saying go live in a cave and just stay
away from everybody don't use technology
don't dress nice don't look good and we
have actually clear a hadith it says
what Allah loves when he bestows money
on you he loves to see the result of
that the result of that is you you know
ducked out looking what is it what did
they say fresh fly what did I say these
days like how you're looking lost a lot
on the law so now it's not to get
hypnotized by the delights of this world
which are only transitory but to get
hypnotized what Allah the crater has
waiting for us huh nice i couldn't have
said it better myself 'not eyes by the
delights of this world it lies you ready
to get rid us do it so now the audience
they can get involved non Muslims and
Muslims you just taught in this world
now and they say I know these Muslims
there in dunya dunya so they can say it
the nonnamous the Muslims can say it and
we'll see it as a fitness category
doesn't it and then we'll discuss it
with the first one
but this can interrupt you so would love
for your non-muslim audience to when
they learn and as they hear the episode
if they catch something happening now if
you have a co-worker who's a Muslim okay
your non-muslim you have a coger yes yes
and you catch him doing some of the
things you go and tell them this has
been your booty exactly yes so when
you're called to prayer and success hi
Alice Ella hyolyn fella that person
rather make tawaf around the mall and
they'd rather go and get entertained by
the baseball football games the xbox
rather than answering the call is this
dunya dunya it seems like that's so you
know when and and let's best example the
prophet saw said listen he was described
that he would sit within hit with his
family at home they would laugh they
would joke they would tell stories but
then the description is fantastic when
he heard the common word he heard the
adhan for for the salah the call to
prayer he would get up as if he did not
know us so it's serious we can joke we
can laugh we can talk about the dunya
but when we hear the abandoned the call
for prayer that's it no more jokes it's
time for prayer you're at the mall
that's it you stop I know people who
spend all day at the mall but when they
when it's time for prayer they go and
pray some of them pray in fitting rooms
but they pray you know but you can't
just keep going around looking at things
or wasting time you know going to these
events that are extremely extended and
long where you you will lose one two
maybe three prayers even and think well
this is okay no that's that's been you
doing so you need to come and answer the
call what will truly give you success is
that relationship with your Lord minimum
five times a day and it's not that
difficult is always aware a place or
somewhere where you can pray it's not
impossible you especially at a mall it
in any place weekend it's better to
answer it now before death once deaf
I've reaches it and you can't answer the
call that's it there was a man who I had
watched a video and he was apparently
got paralyzed and he was now saying I
wish I can make said jus that's all he
wanted just to be able to put it for it
to the ground but then everyone has a
chance to do it now before it's too late
yeah let's go on to another one we're
talking about dunya dunya
do you fit into this do we fit into this
may Allah protect us that we be balanced
and we do things how the Creator wants
us to do things now when a person opens
up their itunes and they find a hundred
pop rock hip-hop songs and what's
excluded go to go to add lift your
lectures things that are nourishment for
the Soul what do we do is this is this a
dunya for sure put it in the dunya dunya
definitely talk about this now this is
the problem you know look generally
entertainment has become an issue where
you know if you look at it when you're
supposed to be entertained right that
means I'm busy I do my thing and then I
come back and I get entertained for a
little bit as a break as a breather and
then I go back to what I'm doing but now
life is entertainment I mean people
their life revolves around entertainment
so suppose and not that I advocate this
but suppose okay I'm a very busy man go
to work and doing all kinds of things
I'm also studying and I I have just no
time for entertainment so every now and
then then I pause and this is just a
hypothetical and then you would watch a
movie or something so this man
entertainment is a small part of his
life not that we're advocating that but
some people their whole life revolves
entertainment so they watch movies
either all day and then they're
listening to music now on top of that
they're now also so immersed and
following the lives of the musicians who
divorced who was I mean this is beyond
entertainment now now you're making it a
life are you basing your life around
people who are just supposed to be there
to make you laugh and to entertain you
yeah I mean it's funny that a comedian
for example his he's like a jester
realistically he's supposed to stand up
and make you laugh so he's like a jester
you're supposed to just laugh at him and
not take him seriously but now these
comedians people take them seriously and
start to revolve their life around them
chasing after them who were they married
to who did they divorce what's happening
with them following their story this is
just someone to entertain you you're not
supposed to be worshipping them now yeah
but this is what has happened so you
look at someone you find that their I
find I could never forget one time I was
on
airplane these young girls who probably
she was 13 or so opened up her laptop I
said mashallah she's gonna read I'm
sitting behind I can see the laptop open
then she opens up a movie and she
minimizes the screen she's watching the
movie while she's watching the movie she
opens up another card game and she's
doing both I mean wow movie card game
record game trying to do as much
entertainment as possible I mean relax a
little bit it's not this is it isn't
this the trick of the Satanic forces
that the day of judgment is coming so
keep you entertained absolutely not
focus on def about your responsibilities
about what you should be doing your
purpose in life you know a mammogram or
less to say something was amazing he's
to say I I always wonder at someone who
laughs like really really really hard
from the depth of his soul he's laughing
so hard and he knows he's gonna die and
he knows who's going to be judgment and
grave and so on so that these are just
his contemplations but what we're saying
people know that they're gonna die
people know that there is heaven in the
Hellfire and yet you plug up your ears
listening to this stuff all night and
day yeah and people now don't even
socialize with each other you see them
walking they don't hear you they don't
greet you because they're so busy
listening to things definitely it's been
your doing let's continue talking about
dunya dunya on the Dean show will be
right back when you look at the Bible
says the earth has four corners the it
is wrong because she can point out a
single unambiguous treatment the GV
sketch peace be upon you says say that I
am God I'm way to accept a penny
back to the Dean show and we are talking
about dunya dunya we were leaving off
with the entertainment let's just spend
another minute on this because I think
this is really crucial Hollywood
Bollywood I mean you're lined up to
watch the next movie and we're not I
mean people who are just just we can't
have some fun I mean we don't want
people to think that there's not some
halau entertainment some things that we
do as Muslims is boring restricted you
know so let's balance this out right I
mean the the problem i'll explain to us
already that it would be impossible for
us to constantly be in the state of
thinking about the the next life and the
hellfire and paradise and he said this
to handle are one of the Companions
Allah unhone he said that if you were
able to remain at that high state of a
man the Angels would come down and shake
your hand and walk with you in the
streets so it's not realistic to expect
someone to be like that and there is
leeway in Islam for people to enjoy
themselves in to laugh and to entertain
it's not serious the whole time but it's
also not a life of entertainment the
entire time to the point where you never
listen to the Quran you never remember
Allah so that you miss your prayers all
of this because of entertainment so it's
neither this nor that not one extreme or
the other it's always the middle not too
fascinated with things of wasting time
and that you have some fun you give
everyone their rights but the first and
most right is to be given to the one who
created you hundred percent hamdulillah
ok next one on the list this is qualify
as dunya dunya or will put into
something else when a person goes to the
house of worship the house of God the
house of Allah to make this a lot but at
the same time to conduct some business
is this dunya dunya she's got to meet up
with someone for business or something
like that at the same time he's going to
make the congregational prayer in the
house of worship the mushroom okay this
is actually not doing it it's not doing
your dinner okay we got our first know
duniya do not donate okay because you
know in this time you can have more than
one intention i can be going to the
mosque because i want to pray in
the time for prayer but I also agreed
with brother so and so let's meet there
and whatever it is I have to hand you
give you your book back or whatever it
is or to even talk about business you
can have more than one intention for
doing something but initially i did when
i went and prayed and everything was for
the sake of allah and there's another
added bonus there I meet up with a
brother or something like that so this
isn't anything okay so this makes sense
now okay you go you offer your prayers
and your going and you have to take care
of some worldly things but your main
attention is to go and worship your
Creator yeah as long as you use less
there it goes back to the intention
right yeah as long you stand there and
you raise your hands and their you're
praying for Allah and you came there to
pray as well not an issue okay now next
one on the list is this going to qualify
for dunya dunya I don't know look we
need you to get involved now you guys be
the judges and can they be free to go
and let's say write these down and then
they can go to their Imam scholars and
say you know what I heard this on the
Dean show and they said this is dunya
dunya what do you have to say can they
do that absolutely and then they could
also think of their own examples and
mail them to the Dean show yeah and then
you compare we get the next episodes
uh-huh and then we can have another one
yes all right keep doing that you tell
us if you like this we can keep doing
the dunya dunya on the Dean show okay
the sister hmm she is more concerned
about chasing the latest fashion
magazines and being hip on that and a
custom more to having and fitting in
with the culture and society around them
but when someone another system mentions
to her about her obligation towards her
Lord and the hijab she shuns away is
this dunya do do you usually don't like
its dunya dunya talk to us a Sufi all
right you know uh and and these are some
of the pressures realistically thank you
got the fashion the hairstyles the
colors and you know fashion part of it
is very embarrassing because like the
psychologists always compare human
beings to sheep and one of the best
examples is fashion today the fashion is
red
now is there a logical reason why it's
red no but it's red so everybody starts
wearing red things red hats Red Sox red
shoes and then tomorrow the fashion
becomes green nobody offers to humanity
a logical explanation why green is the
fashion mm-hmm but everybody just starts
doing it so what happens people get
sucked into this and they start to be so
focused on the fashion and the designer
this and the designer that to the point
where those who can't even afford the
designer item they go get the knockoff
yes to fit in even the knockoff just to
say okay I got the same one yeah but
actually there is an exception that the
scholars make where if you know buying a
particular having a particular item
maybe it's a suit or maybe it's a type
of phone that will give you credibility
business wise or people would not take
you seriously until they see that you
own this particular gadget or you have
this type of camera for example then
here acquiring that item for the sake of
you know it helping you improve your
business what have you this scholars say
it's okay but just chasing after fashion
and running after it like that
especially within the place where it
takes it replaces what is the real
islamic fashion if you want to call it
the fast in the head job right the long
skirt the good modest clothing when you
getting into it to the point where it
replaces that but definitely this is
dunya dunya yeah so we're not talking
about dress nice I mean dress in a way
that looks good but do it according to
how your crater says is the fash the
fashion that sent down from above the
seven heavens absolutely that's the
alternate fashion isn't it so as long as
you're within those guidelines that
you're right okay so nothing wrong with
that but obviously you know tight jeans
and everything's like just bam and bam
and everything's out there and you're
just making it difficult on everybody I
mean for what what are you seeking right
and then attention from who but the
worst part is that here you get you get
you collect a lot of sins for that not
super a woman is not dressed properly
you know if I'm one man sees something
hot on from her she gets a sinful he's
good huh yeah and if two men see
something from she gets to sins for
their if a thousand people see her she
gets a thousand so think of how many
thousands of sins York you
been walking around wearing tight
clothing or revealing clothing everyone
that sees you you get a sin for ya and
it's specially and God forbid you get on
TV looking like that there are millions
of people will see you get millions and
millions of sins who does millions and
millions of good deeds a day to offset
milady millions of sins nobody does that
yeah so it's best in its simple thing
stay away from that but what about if
she gives an excuse well at least I'm
not dressing like her now and you know
what she's according to her logic this
is modest and the thing the way you do
it is that when it comes to religious
things you don't look at those who are
worse than you and say look I'm all
right so like the guy basically you know
he says well my friends all do heroin
hamdullah I just do crack that you can
it doesn't go like that you know you
don't look at people who are you know
half naked and say well I'm semi-naked
oh yeah so I'm all right you look at
those who are better than you and say
look I'm naked compared to them I should
aspire and strive to be like that when
it comes to the dunya dunya here is
where you want to like you you look at
people have less than you so if you have
a decent car you don't look at those who
have like a hundred thousand dollar
Bentley or what have you you look at
those who have no car studying at the
bus station the cold then you feel like
I have more of you know yeah I'm more
thankful for what I have so with again
with the dunya you look at those who
have less than you you thankful for you
have with the religion you look at those
who have more than you you aspire to
become better you don't look at those
who don't have any religion and say okay
well I'm better than this guy yeah that
makes sense can it be just one more note
we'll go to the next one can it be a
sign if you just think a little bit that
let's say you've heard this before the
man or the woman who have been cautioned
about certain acts that they should or
shouldn't be doing and let's say
something happen or like some traffic
tragic they almost had a
life-threatening situation they almost
died alright and now someone's telling
them again the same thing are you know
some people expect a law to have some
bizarre sign that's going to centum he's
gonna come in a dream or so can beat
those be those signs that Allah is
sending them warning them through these
calamities and devices and then watching
the show right now absolutely you know
most like you were saying most people
direct direct contact with other allow
they do this and now it's the time put
on your head job it's not going to work
like that and Allah says insert the rod
the thunder in the Quran that in Fe
delica diet in the whole minute of
Acheron verily in these things are signs
for people who contemplate so you need
to contemplate the signs of Allah before
you recognize that it's a sign from
Allah it's not going to be like a neon
sign telling you specifically what to do
is not any answer yeah it's just
something it could be subtle yeah and if
you think about it you'll notice that
it's a sign from Allah okay we are
almost at the conclusion thank you for
your patience I hope you're having fun
but this is serious at the same time we
want for us and for you for all of us
some change to occur in our very selves
so we can attain paradise so we can be
in a better state when that angel def
comes so the next one on the list is
when Allah the Almighty the creator of
the heavens and earth and His Messenger
have said that dipa commande interests
is something that you should not indulge
and leave it alone and the consensus of
the scholars have explained it but now
you continue to move along and you
convinced by that you know that it's
you're convinced permissible and we
convince and but you are looking for
shake bendel rules to give you some
flimsy football or I'm sorry the thing
that goes with your desires huh is this
dunya dunya mmm that definitely sounds
like it's do yeah yeah yeahs talk to us
talk to us because like you said the guy
knows that it's wrong he's convinced he
knows all the evidences and I've met
many people like this they know that
it's hard I know there's not permissible
they know that the mortgage the usury
the contract all of it is wrong and
they're convinced but because they want
it they look for someone who says it's
okay so basically the idea is that look
I know that it's haram but this guy he's
an imam is reputable you know well-known
speaker in the area he told me that it's
okay so that means on the day of
judgment if I'm asked I'm just going to
point at him and say well he said it's
okay then it's his problem it's still
your problem you know
convinced that it's not permissible you
just went to the person who would give
you the answer you want so that's
definitely dunya dunya is this can we
relate this to a lot of other things
that now you want something to fit
coincide with your desires so now you
start picking and choose your your own
interpretive the crown you're not going
to a qualified person who is someone who
like for a doctor you go to this
specialist but now you'll take the
verses from here and here and come to
your own conclusions I look for someone
who's going to just agree with what you
say this is a big problem this is all
over the place and you find people like
and sometimes you can use this with
people where if you sit at a gathering
and everybody just starts talking about
the religion with no knowledge and
people making fat our left and right you
might tell one of them and you know that
there's not a doctor in the house your
time look I've got this weird lump right
here and when I move my arm this way it
hurts but that way doesn't hurt and
sometimes it gets all red do you think I
should do immediately what are they
going to tell you look I can't give you
advice on that I think you need to go
see a doctor okay so you had you were
you were cautious enough to not give me
advice on something that you didn't know
but speaking about a love with no
knowledge you had no problem with that
whatsoever you know it's so rare now to
meet people who are afraid to speak
about Allah without knowledge everyone
will just will read the verse and just
you know make it to satisfy whatever his
desire is you know or then or otherwise
you know that the verse is saying don't
do it you'll go look for some guy chef
bend the rules who's gonna say hey do it
it's okay so I bend the rule but you're
convinced yeah yeah that guy's famous
it's all over the place and they know
that it's wrong but they go to him
anyways yeah let's leave it on that note
with Sheikh bend the rules and we'll be
right back on the Dean show
alone I am Not Afraid I am Not Afraid
alone I am Not Afraid no problem you can
take my daughter to dinner you and my
daughter and me and let me tell you
something it's natural that's the idea
not created it and he created us to have
a good time you should have a good time
one without wives though Islam is the
fastest growing religion in the world
and most of the converts are women not
men they see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining it the rule set
them free one
back on the Dean show with my brother in
your brother come on Mikey I'm lucky how
you doing brother hundred percent dunya
dunya everybody's now saying it hmm I'll
bet you the whole family's around and
it's a holiday let's see what's next
dunya dunya do you qualify are you in
this position are we we have to check
ourselves and none of us are perfect but
a lot is the most loving the most
merciful but we can't just rely on this
say oh you know allows the most loving
most merciful and I'll just continue
going to see shake bend the rules what I
say about that I mean can we just rely
on that no you can't you got to do
something and you get other what's right
and you gotta do what you know is right
and you know some of these examples
might apply to someone you might be
sitting with people now and then one of
them applies to you yeah I be the next
one we do and you'll be like okay yeah
we need to fix that we need to fix it so
now the brother hassan the brother james
the brother so and so I mean this and
there's a lot of details because this is
a complete way of life so the main thing
is that we worship God alone Allah we
establish the prayer we do what Allah
wants you to do and then all the other
things that fall in place we slowly try
to commit to it yes now the brother
realizes ok this is another detail of
Islam it's not something that is the
main pillar but it's an obligation it's
a fun on the mail to be able to
distinguish himself from the female one
of the things is the beard absolutely so
he realizes this but now his boss is
pressuring him to shave to take it off
is this dunya dunya absolutely not it's
not this is not the nitin because so
basically the man realizes that in Islam
you have to grow your beard so he starts
to grow his beard his boss is pressuring
him to remove it it's not good for
business customers will be scared so you
have to remove it and the man is
insisting not to because it's his right
to do so and so basically then this is
not tony tony he's following what he's
commanded to do you know Eddie that the
beard issue now whenever you say the
word beard is like oh he's one of those
beard people again no I haven't we moved
past the issue of the beard why are you
bringing up the beard again yeah it's a
command of Allah so you'll come out of
prophets allah said them how do we move
past any of the good Isola sorry What
did he say remind the people so many
times people will tell you you know you
don't talk to us about beers and this is
you know we've got bigger issues we've
got bigger issues we've got people dying
all over the world Muslims being killed
but things have what it what it uh what
are the prophecy I'm sorry the process
LM saying he commanded us he said you
know he said grow the beard or leave
along the beard mean do not take from it
and trim your mustache yeah so this is
the command from the process of Salem
you know and and so the scholars say a
lot I mean a lot of things are wrong
with shaving so you change the creation
of love because males have facial hair
you resemble women because they don't
have facial hair you disobey you go
against the command of the prophets of
the law said lemon this is something
that all the prophets is well had that
if they all had facially so the possum
commanded leave it that's it you know
something the what has become the you
know the image of a good-looking guy is
the guy who is what they call
clean-shaven I call the dirty shaven
yeah because if that means if that's
clean shaven and we're just dirty / yeah
yeah so so now the guy with no beard
that's the style that's clean that's
good that's business like that's
presentable now one chef was saying that
if in the West the the the notion was to
grow the beard and in if Islam said
shave people living in the West we start
growing their beards let me describe it
a little bit but when a lot of you know
the problem commands it is just you know
whatever or people look at it as it's
just optional if you want to do it or
not it's not about the facial hair it's
not about your appearances its what's
about then all the fort art did all the
four imams someone can say oh this is a
different method but you found that all
the four imams a great imams that they
agree to this this is no mother habitué
there's nothing about my dad consensus
yeah everybody was there was a situation
someone approached you in our muslim
said you know why you why do you grow
this right yeah and someone said why do
you grow your beard and basically I in
another way turned it around and said
why do you shave because I told him I
don't grow it it comes out by itself and
he understood and he said you know
you're right I shouldn't have asked you
that question you should have asked me
why do I shave because he's the one who
wakes up every
winning and insist to remove what will
naturally come out no so but it got him
to think about it now but again people
don't want to hear about the beard they
don't want to hear about things that
make them uncomfortable yeah what about
the child you know naturally if the
child if you asked to paint a picture I
like this analogy yeah when you tell the
child draw the face of a man and a woman
they naturally will add facial hair to
the man they'll add a mustache or beard
because they know this isn't something
that natural happens to mail the hair
facial hair started to sprout so it's a
natural thing so actually you're going
against what's natural and you're
getting all the cuts and Nick's and
everything and putting the Cologne on it
that's a lot that's a lot of pain every
morning is there a priority now that we
should give let's say someone's new to
the Dean and now he's not even
establishing the prayer should how
should this thing's these be balanced
out what is to be given priority we just
have a few more minutes can you just
clarify on great and someone who just
comes into Islam and no one is ever
expecting that person to make a change
overnight at all but sometimes people
would say things like don't shave your
beard take off your gold ring remove
your earring did it just first things
first first and most important thing is
to establish the link with a low which
is the prayer so the first thing is the
person gets to pray and a lot does is in
the Quran that the prayer will prevent
the sins and reprehensible acts and
wicked deeds later on so the first
things first get people to pray and
things like that but we're talking about
a specific situation where someone prays
and everything and knows that they were
commanded to grow the beard but you know
they shave it and it may have some of
the dunya effect there as well okay
where they're signaling we're almost out
of time just to bring this fact home I
mean a lot of times I mean in any
institution any corporation or any
alumni school there are certain details
certain rules that you have to follow
you have the main pillar of it the main
structure but then certain things that
you just have to do so these are the
details of Islam and how do we now we
look at it just like you would join a
company and they would have you do all
these little procedures a law is the
most wise he has told us to do these
things so how do we look at it from a
light where people can rationally
understand some of these things so they
can see and is it wrong to ask sometimes
why
is the wisdom ok no differently you can
ask for the wisdoms but the reason is
clear the reasons a lot told us to do it
the wisdoms will become clear once you
examine and contemplate inshallah ok so
now we are out of time I like to thank
you for being with us but here on the
Dean show inshallah we'll have you back
you're going to be back for any time on
my pleasure yeah ok they heard it it's a
testimony na na na all right and thank
you for being with us on another episode
of the Dean show you have to pray as if
everything depends on a lot and it does
but you must work everything depends on
you and it doesn't that's my point you
see the same and I don't like that I
don't like us sitting here what are you
waiting for what are you waiting for
right now what are you waiting for all
these people to come to this long what
are you waiting for what are we waiting
for right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come to logon bring these
people lots of pot of water put in our
hand the ability to do it now do your
job
Oh